Okay. We're still talking
about addition to alkenes
and we've looked at these various,
uh,
electro file come nuclear
files and into alkenes.
And now at the beginning of last time,
we introduced the idea of Osmium tetroxide
and we'll go on to per Megan aid as
reagents for Di hydroxylation of alkenes.
Then we'll go onto things
involving transition metals,
catalytic hydrogenation, and
also metathesis and, and, uh,
catalyzed polymerization.
So last time we looked at the end that
Oso for which looked a little bit like oh
three and could do the same trick oh
three could do to give this Awesomei
Tester, which is like an asset towel. Uh,
so it's possible to add water and get
the osmium equivalent of a carpet eal
group and the two a hydroxyl groups
added to the Termini of the alkene.
So, uh, the problem with this is always,
oh four is a very
efficient reagent for that,
but it's poisonous and
it's also very expensive.
So you have to figure out some
way not to use so much of it.
And the way you could do it is to use
just a little bit of it as a catalyst and
put hydrogen peroxide in there,
uh,
in order to convert the osmium equivalent
of trioxide back to the tetroxide
again so it can cycle around and
keep doing, uh, the reaction.
In fact, it was improved in, uh,
in 1976 by using a different
oxidizing agent. This n oxide,
uh, uh, uh, uh, the morpholine oxide.
And in fact it's called
the Upjohn process,
which is relevant because the guy who's
picture is over here who a state gave
the money for redoing this room a while
back was the research director at Upjohn
laboratories. Uh, so anyhow, that
was a good way to do it. But then,
uh, we should notice something
about the stereo chemistry of this.
We showed here a trans to beauty.
And of course, if it's like ozone,
the two oxygens, we'll add at the same
time, therefore it at the same face.
So the configuration you get at the two
carbons where the Oah adds a Oeh is ad
are related to one another. They
could be ss as shown here. Of course,
the Osmium tetroxide could equally well
have come in from the bottom or that or
the,
uh,
to beauty and could have been turned
over and then you would have gotten rr.
So of course you don't get [inaudible]
without starting with [inaudible].
That is a single car rally a,
however you can start with it in
a ligand that attaches to the,
to the osmium.
So if you use a chiral amine ligand,
then you only get one of the two,
uh,
eat and teamers of the dihydroxy,
c Dye hydroxylated alkene.
And this you won't be surprised to hear
was also invented by professor Sharpless
when we talked about, uh, last semester
with respect to, to, uh, adding, uh,
oxygen. And so this is called the
Sharpless asymmetric die hydroxylation.
He invented it in 1988 and I think this
room was the first place he talked about
it in public. He, he, uh,
he was standing right there and in
fact he did a demonstration on the,
on this table as I'm going to do at the
end, but I'm going to do a different dis,
uh,
different demonstration because Osmium
tetroxide which he uses very dangerous
and poisonous and he went and he
actually spilled it on this table.
I think it's now long
gone since that was 1988,
but at least what I'm going to do just
use as vinegar so you don't have to worry
about that. Okay. So anyhow, this, here's,
here's a specific example of using
Sharpless, asymmetric dihydroxy colation.
With that dying,
it gives a 97% in anti more excess of the,
of the indicated configuration here.
Okay?
Now that per Manga,
Nate is much cheaper and looks very
much like osmium tetroxide so it won't
surprise you that it also
can do this trick. Uh,
and here you, you get a 85%
yield with cyclohexene and again,
it's a sin addition.
The two o h has come in on the same face,
but that's not one where
there's a catalyst that will
make it give only one and
a half timer. Okay. Now onto
catalytic hydrogenation.
So we looked before at
the idea of drawing, uh,
two curved arrows and making h two add
to an alkene and saw that the orbitals
weren't set up for that homo
would match Homo Lumo with Lumo.
So there's no profit in
that. However, we said,
even though that doesn't work,
that it does work if you have a metal
catalin [inaudible] like palladium or
platinum or many other transition metals.
So let's look a little bit at how it
is that palladium does this trick.
It does it by providing orbital variety
rather than just having the orbitals
that we showed before the sigma of sigma
and sigma star of the HH Bond and the
Pi and Pi Star of the alkene.
You have lots of different shapes of
orbitals on the metal. For example,
in ethylene we have the
Pi and the Pi Star, right?
But in the metal,
palladium has four d ten
five s zero and five p zero.
So, uh, the occupied orbitals of,
of palladium then are this Dz square.
Now is that set up to overlap?
Well with a Pi Star,
the homo below and the Lumo above.
What do you think?
Is that going to be a good reaction?
Who's gotten opinion? Carl?
To get
one side of the rent overlap and then
maybe on one side but not as shown there.
Right? That's what you're
saying that yeah, you're right.
They're orthogonal as drawn.
But there are other d orbitals.
There are five of these d orbitals so we
could check out others. How about the D,
Y, z? Is that going to do the trick?
Are you going to get overlap
if you bring that up?
Okay.
What do you say?
If you turn to, you could, but
it has shown it's orthogonal.
Right?
Okay.
How about that one?
That's going to do the trick.
Okay.
No, Chris is shaking his head right.
Won't do it. How about that one?
Well, it's still one of them
is symmetrical, right to left.
The other is anti symmetric, right
to left, so they'd have no overlap.
How about that one? Ah, just right. Okay.
So that one can come up and overlap and
stabilize the electrons that were on the
metal. And that new orbital shown
there is in fact the homo minus four.
It's gotten quite stable. Right? In fact,
part of the reason it got stable is the
nature of the orbitals changes as Adams
come up and meet the geometry changes.
So this is not all those two,
although it looks very much like those
two original orbitals and in a sense came
from them. By the time it gets
to this point, at the complex,
it's 40% of that DXY or but along the
bottom 47% actually on the top is Sigma
Chi has, but 13% is still
the Pi Star. So that is,
that's just to tell you the ugly truth,
but the fact is that the reaction began
and went through a transition state
because of the mixing of those orbitals.
So that's two electrons.
But how about the other way around?
How about if we use the homo on the top?
Now of course we have all these d orbitals
on the bottom and few of them would
overlap.
And even that one,
which does overlap you don't care
about because it's homo with Homo.
Okay,
we want unoccupied orbitals on the bottom,
which means that five s and five p.
So there's the five p,
that's an unoccupied orbital.
That's gonna overlap well,
and there's the five s it'll overlap.
So you use some mixture of those two.
You'll use a hybrid orbital, an sp
hybrid of some sort on the palladium,
which will overlap with that homo and
stabilize another pair of electrons.
And there it is in the complex and you
see it's a hybrid orbital below and the
Pi orbital above forming that new bond,
stabilizing those electrons.
In fact, if you look at the
ugly truth of the on this one,
by the time you get to the complex has
changed the 67% of pie and it's uh,
11% of an sp hybrid,
but it's also 15% of that d orbital
that we showed at the beginning.
So things have gotten mixed up,
but that's the way it happened because
you had these vacant orbitals that could
overlap from below on the metal overlap
with pie, you had the filled orbital,
the particular one, the particular d
orbital, that can overlap with Pi Star.
So you stabilize two pairs of electrons.
That means you make two
new bonds to the alkene.
Okay?
So the palladium or platinum,
or many of these transition metals can do
this trick of adding, uh, at, at the two,
at the same time to the alkene.
Now you can also do it to sigma bonds.
So here's palladium reacting with h two.
It's just sigma and Sigma Star now,
right? But if that's the energy of the
starting material and a pretty crummy
calculation,
so don't hang your hat on this,
these are successive stages as
you go left to right. First you,
you begin to associate the age two
with the palladium and bond to it.
Then the h two gets even closer, and
as it gets closer and closer, the,
the hydrogen spread apart.
And the reason I've drawn them up
and down a little bit is to show, uh,
energy minima and transition states.
So first you get the h two associated
with the palladium without very close
contact, right? Then it gets closer,
it goes over a transition state and
becomes this one which is closer bonded.
And then you the h the,
the two hydrogens come apart and get
quite far apart, right? But notice,
at least in this calculation and
in some others, as you'll see,
it goes uphill a little bit.
So that would seem to be unfavorable.
You could do it, you could split the
hydrogen apart on the metal, right?
But in terms of of out kilocalories
per mole, it's up hill. However,
once it gets up there,
these hydrogens can move from one metal
to the next because we're talking a
solid metal in this
case. Okay? So in fact,
it dissociates on the palladium
surface and then the high drives move.
So you get into advantage from entropy,
from the hydrogens getting apart.
Even though it's uphill
a little bit in energy,
it's very favorable to move them apart
in entropy rather than having to have
them right next to one another.
So it's possible to dissociate
a hydrogen on palladium.
Now let's, and here's,
here's a a calculation,
certainly better than the previous one,
was published in the Journal of physical
chemistry in 2004 and it shows the same
thing. Palladium approaching hydrogen
above Palladian approaching methane below.
And again, I don't think that
these are great numbers probably,
but it gives you the idea of what I
showed on the previous slide and some
specific geometries. Okay. Now,
catalytic hydrogenation puts these two
reactions together that we just looked at.
You have what you call ox,
what inorganic chemists
call oxidative edition.
That's where we do this,
which we just saw as possible
to electronics can get
stabilized because of the
orbitals that are available to form
something like a three member during here.
Right?
And that's called oxidative addition.
The reason it's called oxidative is
the way in organic chemists, electrons,
they say that the,
if you have a bond to metal,
those electrons belonged to the,
to the league and not to the metal.
So electrons formally had been
taken away from the metal.
We'll talk more about oxidation and
reduction before too long, but anyhow,
that's called oxidative edition. But of
course you could do the reverse as well.
You could do reductive elimination and
Paul, the owl keyed back off again.
Okay, now you'd do the same thing
with hydrogen as we just saw.
So you could have oxidative addition.
Those two arrows move like that.
And then the to give that
and then the blue reverse,
the reductive elimination and
you're back where you started.
But now suppose you do
both of these things. Okay?
Let's suppose that we first
do the oxidative addition,
the insertion of palladium into
the HH Bond, and one of the H's,
let's say moves away and now we have room
on the surface of the palladium there
to bring in the alkene and do its trick.
Okay,
so now we have this form.
Now,
of course you could do reductive
elimination again. Now, incidentally,
in that form, the experts discuss just
how much the different bonds are formed.
Sometimes they draw it this way and
just say the alkene is complex, but the,
but that begs the question of what is
it that's holding the arche in there?
And it's those orbital
interactions that we looked at.
The electrons going one way,
the electrons go in the other,
so we'll abbreviate will,
uh,
for our purposes of our lecture today
will will say that the bonds are
completely formed even
though they may not be okay.
So you could do a reductive
elimination that could come off again,
but suppose you did the
other reductive elimination.
Suppose you did that one.
Okay,
now you're over here and
you've put hydrogen on one
carbon and palladium on the
other.
Right.
Now suppose we that hydrogen that's
wandering around the surface.
Suppose we bring it back.
Can you see what I'm going to do now,
Chris,
do you have an idea of what's that next?
What about the title of the slide?
We want to put a hydrogen on each of the
carbons. How are we going to do that?
We've got a hydrogen on
the right carbon already.
How do we get a hydrogen on the left card,
Lydia? Yeah, and the carbon is bonded.
The palladium and what will we
call the process that gets that?
He gets the hydrogen bond with the carbon
instead of the carbon and the hydrogen
bomb at the palladium substitution.
Nope,
it's that.
Anybody got a name for that?
That's the reduction elimination.
The blue thing we've been talking
about. All these, right? They come on,
they come off, they
come on, they come off.
But if you put them on one way
and take them off a different way,
you've done the trick. Got It. Okay.
Now notice that that addition
of the palladium to the, the,
the oxidative addition of Alkene to
palladium happened too at the same time.
So they come in on the same face.
It's a sin edition and then
when the hydrogens replaced,
replaced palladium,
they come in on the front side
is not a backside attack. Okay.
When we curve those two errors,
it's not attacking backside.
So they come in from
the same side as well.
So the overall product is sin edition.
The H's came in on the same here,
the bottom face of the double bond.
And of course if you put methyl groups
on there and it were to beauty and then
you'd expect to get that particular
isomer of the beauty and where the two
hydrogens operated added on the same side.
Of course you couldn't tell it because
the other two things would be hydrogens
as well.
How could you tell,
how could you tell that the
two came in on the same side?
You wouldn't use hydrogen. What would
you use? You use deuterium as you say.
Yeah. So then you can
tell this. There'd be,
and here's an example from the book
where they use Deuterium and, and uh, uh,
platinum oxide in this case.
And the two ds came in on the same side.
Okay.
That was not necessary in this case to
tell because you also had the cyclohexane
ring there. So it's a, it says here,
the Deuterium is added in a sin fashion.
It's a sin edition.
And here's a typical passage
from another textbook.
The loud and textbook that we use several
years ago about stereochemistry of
this addition reaction,
catalytic hydrogenation,
and it says Stereo specific
sin addition happens.
It says for most alkenes
and it gives us example,
but this I'm,
I'm actually doing this little bit to
show you how to read textbooks, right?
So it says most alkenes do this and give
stereo specific second edition and it
gives an example, but notice it
doesn't say what the yield is.
It could be one of these things.
Remember last time we said
there was a 55 45 right?
That was said to be specific
or to favor one over the other.
So it doesn't say what the yield is and
it doesn't give any reference to the
literature where you could look up and
see what the yield was or how they did it
or how much of the other isomer
there might've been there.
Now this is very typical for textbooks
and I have no doubt that this happens
with, with high specificity in
this case, but on the other hand,
you shouldn't be satisfied with that.
So you would look in another book like
this book from 1972 by house modern
chemistry.
Now this is a graduate level text.
So it shows an example here using
palladium on carbon is the catalyst.
Palladium on carbon means
you have palladium metal,
but you don't want to have a big chunk of
metal because there's not much surface.
So you want it to be very finely divided,
but you want to be able to handle it.
You don't have very much.
So you put it on charcoal,
it's absorbed on the
surface of the charcoal.
So that's what palladium on carbon is.
So it's done in a Siddique
acid with hydrogen gas at
one atmosphere and you have
that a double bond.
And what do you notice about the
stereo chemistry of the product?
Is it ascend edition,
which is the product of
sin addition Sebastian,
the one on the left or the right,
the one on the left,
the two came in on the same side on
the right. One came in at the top,
one on the bottom,
and 90% of the product is the wrong one.
The one the book tells you, or almost any
book will tell you, it's us in addition.
And it often is, okay. Now, uh,
look at this example from 1948
what's going on here? This is a,
this is Barton in 1948.
Anybody else?
Remember what Martin was talking about
in 1948 or 49 from last semester?
He,
that was the first confirmational analysis
and it was molecules very like this.
So this is what he was working
on these steroids, okay.
But notice these two compounds
are Al Lilly isomers.
They only differ in the
position to that double bond.
There are three carbons in a row and a
double bond between two of them, right?
That's an how lily system.
So these are isomers where you move a
hydrogen from the top to the bottom,
and now you have a double bond
here in a single bond here.
So those are Al Lily Chi Summers,
right?
And now if you look at the details
of this primary literature,
it says that there's a rearrangement
of one of these compounds to the other,
right?
And it says that it happens in 80% yield,
80% of the product has
gone from here to here.
This is what you would use
for catalytic hydrogenation.
But instead of hydrogenating at
first went by Alec Rearrangement.
Now how did that happen?
So let's look back again at the mechanism
of the catalytic hydrogenation. First,
you have the oxidative addition
to that of the double bond.
And then you have the reductive
elimination on the right to put the first
hydrogen on,
okay?
And then you put the other hydrogen on
the left and continue. But of course,
that reaction would be reversible.
You could have not only put this,
you could have, uh, you could, uh,
have taken this back off
again in the wrong way, right?
And instead of going there apartment,
you could, you could go there,
but the other thing you could have done
is if there's an Al Lily hydrogen in the
compound you're talking about. So dot.
Only the allocate, but the next door
carbon has a hydrogen on it. You're here,
you're here, you're here, you're
here, you get to there, okay.
And now one possibility
is to reverse that way.
That's the reductive elimination,
uh,
are probably oxidative addition that
takes you back here that undoes those blue
arrows and would take you back.
But what other option is there?
Can anybody see another option?
Leon?
Aha.
That compound is symmetric if
you have an Lla hydrogen, right?
So it could unzip that way too.
Okay.
And now instead of going back to this,
you go back to this,
right? And if that, uh, uh,
does the reduction elimination,
right?
You come back here and now you'll notice
that's has I saw him rise the Alkene,
right?
The double bond moved next door.
Okay.
So it's all these oxidative addition,
reductive eliminations. But if,
but if you go through that
symmetric intermediate,
then you can take the wrong one off. I
should go back towards starting material.
Uh, so they started material is
actually, I saw him rise product.
So that's presumably how it happens.
So catalytic hydrogenation can
lead the aloe rearrangement.
And now let's go back and
look at that paper, right?
And we see that if,
if we had that rearrangement,
this could go to this. In fact, it
could go to four different eyes.
It could be the double bond here
or here, or here or here, right?
So we could come back to this. And now
once you're here, if you add hydrogen,
even if you added from the same side,
those two hydrogens,
they could be the opposite side from
where the first hydrogen was, right?
So now you could expect to get this
and you'd expect more of this than this
because that form is more
stable. It's, it's uh,
conformationally a better,
uh, a better structure. Okay,
so 90% there.
Now the nice thing is you don't have to
even look at the secondary literature
going back to the primary literature
because it gives a reference here.
So we could look at that reference and
see here where they give the table about
studying these things.
And down here in row seven,
you see they're talking about compounds
seven Delta nine, 10, [inaudible]. So the,
the ring is numbered in a certain way,
and the double bond is
between nine and 10. Okay?
Now if they started with that material,
you see they got 90% of the Trans Product.
That's this one.
That's what show near 90% 10% okay.
But if they,
if they did only partial hydrogenation,
they still got 90% of this,
but they had a 100% after
doing 80% of the hydrogenation.
It says here they did at 80%
after doing that, they have,
they don't have any of this
stuff. It's all this stuff, right?
So if these things could
go back and forth, right?
It must be that the equilibrium
lies in this direction.
And occasionally when you get over
here, you go onto the product, right?
And that's the explanation of it.
But it's interesting to look even a
little closer to look at what happened if
they started with eight.
So suppose they start with eight.
If you start,
if it started at seven and you can
go through eight to get down here,
you get 90% of the product.
That's their explanation.
Suppose you start with pure eight,
what should you get?
Okay.
In terms of the product. If you didn't
have seven, if you start with eight,
Debbie,
you've got an idea,
you should get at least this
much, maybe more, right?
If the way you get here,
if some of it goes this way and some of
it goes this way and you start here and
get 10 to 90 if you start here,
you should get even more
than 90 to 10 right?
Because you don't have the chance of
going here initially. Got It. Okay.
What does it say?
You get 80%
so there's something rotten here,
but no one's ever talked about it.
It could be just that the experiments
weren't done really carefully or maybe the
catalyst was a different little bit
different in one pace than the other.
I don't know what the answer is,
but it's when you go back to look at
the dig in to where the real results are
that you find things that are interesting.
So evidently this isn't a
hundred percent understood,
but I have no doubt that this aloe
lake arrangement rearrangement is a big
source of getting what appears
to be the wrong edition.
That it really is an addition, but it
happens after you've rearranged things.
So the product isn't what you
would have expected naively. Okay.
Now the a process called
metathesis of an alkene.
This was reported,
uh,
when I first came here to Yale the first
year I was here and it was amazing.
People were amazed by this reaction
and the mechanism was quite on,
uh, uh, speculative. Nobody had any
idea what happened at the beginning.
But in the subsequent, uh,
whatever number of years, 45 years,
it's been figured out.
And what is involved is a double
bond from the metal to carbon.
Of course there are,
there are two other things on the carbon,
but this is called an owl Kyla
deep and complex. And in fact,
this process was,
this was the basis for
the Nobel prize in 2005,
which went to grubs.
Okay.
So this is a metal al Kyla Dean complex.
We come in with an alkene and do the
oxidative addition to form that and a
reductive elimination. So it
gives a Metalla, cyclo butane,
a cycle of butane that has a metal in it,
right?
Just by the same processes we
talked about on the previous slide.
Now those processes are reversible.
And what do you notice about reversing it?
Leon? What about the intermediate here?
It's symmetrical so you can
reverse the other direction,
right to go to there and
then that can come apart.
And you've put the central carbon,
the one that's here changed it from
being attached to this carbon to being
attached to this carbon.
So you can take effectively to
alkenes and mix up their carbons,
which is double bonded
to which, okay, now,
uh, you, you've heard of Professor
Ziegler who teaches the other, uh,
Hu last semester taught the other
organic of course. Uh, he's,
I don't know if you've seen him around in
the lab. They, but he's unusually tall.
He's six,
six or something like that.
And I point out here that he's
not professor Karl Ziegler.
We'll talk about Professor Karl
Ziegler a few slides later,
but he was visiting Japan in 1986
in this delegation of a junior high.
Girls thought he was so tall they
should get their picture taken with him,
which is here, but he wasn't the only
tall guy visiting Japan at that time.
Here he is touring together
with professor grubs.
The guy that got the Nobel prize in
2005 who is equally tall. In fact,
professor grubs is a daughter, played
basketball at Yale. She's quite tall.
I think she holds the rebounding
record for women's basketball. Yeah.
So this will help you remember
professor grubs, I hope. Okay. In fact,
they took another picture together with
their host at the professor more Ohashi.
So again, I underline that there
unusually tall people. Okay.
But grubs invented a process called
romp ring opening metathesis,
polymerization.
Now here's a double bond where both of
the carbons in the double bond are part
of the same molecule,
the same framework.
So if you cleave that double bond and
exchange partners with something else,
right, you still have the two linked
together through this other ring, right?
So if you bring in this alkylating
compound and do the trick of metathesis,
you get that.
And now if you do you,
the product is still an alkylating,
a ruthenium here.
So you can do that with another
one of these molecules. In fact,
you can do it with n of the molecules
and they'll all link together in a chain
like this to give a polymer,
right?
So this ring opening metathesis was the,
uh,
was a very important part of this.
Uh,
Nobel prize work degenerate.
A polymer,
okay. Now a catalytic hydrogenation
we saw looked like this,
but Ziegler,
Nada polymerization.
This is the other Ziegler
Carl sealer. Uh, German, uh,
looks very similar,
so it has to Tanium with it,
with an r group on it.
Okay.
And now an alkene comes in oxidative
edition to give this reductive elimination
on the other side.
It was that,
but now that we could just
call a different art group,
it's not the original art group at CR
group with two carbons in between, right?
That we just brought in.
Now what can you do?
You could bring it back to
start over again, right?
And that'll be the r and then
you bring it in and that's the r.
And then you do it again
and again and again,
and you could make a very long chain
of ethylene molecules. For example.
Now Ziegler found this,
I,
I contacted grubs a yesterday in order
to get permission to show his picture on
to you, add more Ohashi as
well. And Ziegler incidentally.
But he told me an interesting story of
how Siegler uh, uh, discovered this.
He was trying,
it was during the Second World War and
in Germany they were short of lubricating
oil.
So he was trying to figure out how to
use triethyl aluminum to add to alkenes
and then Paul liberal rise on the basis
of that to get things that could be
lubricating oils.
And after the war he continued that work,
but sometimes they found different
products rather than these oils they were
trying to make and they traced it to
the presence of metals in the reactor.
So then they tried all different salts
and when they use titanium tetra chloride,
they found that they had made a
heterogeneous cutout catalyst for
polymerization.
The thing that I show in here now,
I underlined that this is heterogeneous.
You mix these things together,
it's a witch's brew and nobody knows
really exactly what's in there and it's,
it's not. And the reason you don't
know is because it's a solid,
it's not a pure crystal and compound is
not something in solution that you can
do spectroscopy on to figure
out exactly what it is.
So it's very hard to study the mechanism
with these heterogeneous catalysts,
but that doesn't mean they're not useful.
For example, high density polyethylene,
the number two of your recycling thing,
uh,
with ends of from 800 to a
quarter million chain length,
it was made in 2004 to the tune
of 25 times 10 to the sixth tons,
25 million tons,
right?
Or polypropylene with up to
10 to the five units in a,
in a chain.
Again,
45 million tons in 2007.
So this Ziegler not a catalyst was a
really a revolutionary thing for making a
polymers, but it was hard
to do the mechanisms. Okay.
Now,
one thing that we'll see later that free
radicals also can pull them arise thing
can polymerize, uh, uh, alkenes.
But the difference here is that these
are ISO tactic that you get from,
from Siegler, not of polymerization. Uh,
so I should tell you what tactility is,
okay?
So if you have a polymer
chain and the alkenes had,
say methyl groups on it,
propylene instead of ethylene,
then you have a bunch of stereo centers.
Okay?
Now notice that every
alkene went in head to tail.
That is Cah two then ch, ch, ch, ch,
ch three ch two ch ch
three ch two ch ch three.
Okay? So it's head to tail,
but it stereo regular,
all the methyls are coming out at
you and that's called ISO tactic.
Okay?
And alternative would be all had detail,
but Syndeo tactic out, back out, back out,
back every other one,
okay.
And of course it could
be random out and back.
So there are these three different,
uh, fundamental types of polymers.
Eissa tactic, sidio
tactic at a tactic, right?
And they have different properties and
we'll talk about polymer properties in
the next lecture and why they
should be different. So depends.
So for some purposes, you'd want
one for some another. Okay. Now,
there are two questions
that would address here.
One is how do you know which is which?
How do you know whether you have an ice,
a tactic, or a Cindy,
a tactic or a tactic?
And for that you got to wait until
we get to Nmr. It's coming very soon.
It's a really neat way to
figure out which is which.
But if more fundamental question is,
how do you control what you make?
Right? So there's, there
are these catalysts.
Instead of using titanium,
use these zirconium catalysts,
which are homogeneous,
that means they're dissolved there,
not some solid that's in there.
So it's possible to do
spectroscopy on these things.
And Kamensky the name associated with
this Catallo esis has to do with his
accidental discovery that adding
Mao makes these very reactive.
Mao is methyl aluminum taxane,
which is a sophisticated name for
something that nobody knows what it is,
that you mix stuff together and you
get that. And it's not always the same.
But if you add it to the, uh, to the,
these zirconium dichloride complexes,
you get a very active catalyst.
So this is there. There had been,
I think since this was discovered in
1980 I think there've been something like
7,000 papers written on it or
something like that and 2000 patents.
Okay.
Now,
one thing that's pretty much agreed on
is that what this methyl aluminum taxane
takes the chlorides off,
puts an art group like methyl on the
zirconium and leaves it as a cad. I am.
Okay.
Now what happens next?
The alkenes approach,
but they approached from alternate faces.
Let's see what that means.
So here we take propylene and bring
it into the front to make one of these
complexes and then the r group
shifts across and you make a bond.
Okay.
Have you ever seen a reaction like that
where you have a metal with a group
attached to it?
Alkane comes up and you form a bond
here and this thing comes over?
Yeah,
right. The Bh Hydro duration is
exactly that same kind of thing.
Okay. Now, so we'll call
that new group our prime.
The original one was our,
but now the next alkene comes in and
associates with the Sercos Niamh.
But what's different from the first one?
I drew.
It's now in the back, right? The
first Al King came in in the front.
So it goes on the back.
Now the our prime moves back there and
then the next al comes in in front and it
comes over there and so on and so on.
And you build a long chain.
But notice every, every other
one is reacting in front,
in, back, in front and back.
Now let's compare the
front and back of this,
of this zirconium complex.
Notice it has an axis of symmetry there.
If you rotate 180 degrees
about that access of symmetry,
you get the same thing again. So the
front and the back are super imposable.
They look just the same.
So whatever happens in front with respect
to stereochemistry will happen the
same way in back.
So that will give the,
the two faces fronted back or homo topic.
They're the same.
So you'll get the same chemistry,
the same stereochemistry at either one.
Now how is it different in this case that
instead of having an axis of symmetry
has a mirror plane of symmetry, what does
that mean about the front? And the back.
Sebastian,
what do you say?
What's the relationship between the front
and the back? Are they super imposable?
So what would you call them?
Right? So those are in Antio topic.
So whatever one's face does,
the other one will do the opposite.
And as you bounced back and forth what
product or you're going to get now
it'll be Syndeo tactic,
right?
And now suppose you take this one,
which has a horizontal plane,
which means the top and the bottom are,
are both accessible on the front.
You can go either,
either the top or the bottom equally.
So there's no selection. So what do
you think you're going to get now
if it doesn't make any
difference which way you go
right
now the faces are a chiral and
you get an eight tactic product,
so you can control which one you
get by choosing the symmetry of the,
of the a league. And that's
attached to the zirconium. Okay.
Now, as I said is I promised you can
also do free radical polymerization.
I said we'd discussed
that. So, uh, uh, fruit,
this was the earliest kind
of polymerization studied
in laboratories. Okay.
So Al comes in. Bingo, another one. Bingo.
Bingo, Bingo. Bingo. So
we're growing along chain,
but the difference is that in this case
you can get rotation around this bond
to get that form. And when you do that
radical is close to this hydrogen.
And you can go from a primary
radical to a secondary radical.
Hey, that's downhill. Okay.
And now you can add an alkene to that.
Okay.
So if you do radical polymerization as
opposed to doing these metal catalyzed
polymerizations,
you can get branches,
you get occasional butyl chains,
c four chains stuck on your long chain.
And that means that they don't
pack together as efficiently.
So it's not as crystal
on, right? So that gives,
since it doesn't pack as well,
it's not as dense.
So that gives low density polyethylene,
the kind of stuff that you
get in a dry cleaner bags,
that flimsy stuff as opposed to what
you would get in a supermarket to carry
groceries in, which is tougher
and, and uh, and opaque.
Okay, now let's look at it again. And
we start polymerization going fine.
Free radical polymerization.
But we may not want it to keep going
because properties of the polymer,
like its viscosity, it's melting point,
depends on how long the chain is.
We may want to control
how long the chain is.
How can we control the
length of the chain, right?
One way to control the polymer chain
length is to add a molecule like carbon
tetrachloride. There are
many such reagents, not just
carbon tetrachloride. Okay,
now the radical could attack
the chlorine like this,
right?
And now you have a try. Chloro methyl
radical in your chain is done right?
But you have the tri
chloro methyl radical.
So it can I add to another alkene
and then that one can grow a new chain.
So you see what you've done by this
is used what's called a chain transfer
agent. It doesn't destroy
the, the kinetic chain, right?
The radical still keeps working,
but on a new molecule.
So you shorten the polymer molecules
without terminating the chain reaction.
So if you add more of the chain
transfer agent, you get shorter chains.
So if you measure the rate of the
transfer of the reaction with the carbon
tetrachloride versus the rate constant
for preliminary ization in the particular
case of styrene and carbon tetrachloride,
that ratio is 0.01,
right?
So if,
if you don't have to worry
about radicals finding radicals,
they're fee rather dilute,
then the molecular length will be how
likely it is to react with styrene
compared to how likely it is to react
with carbon tetrachloride and terminate
the chain.
But that depends on the concentration
of styrene and the concentration.
So if you know these, do, uh, if you
have, you can, you can then work out,
uh, since the, the, uh,
the transfer reaction with this,
this process here is only 1% as fast.
So if you had equal amounts of
styrene and carbon tetrachloride,
you'd tend to go about a hundred
molecules before you got a chain transfer.
So you'd get on average
about a hundred molecular,
hundred units in a chain.
If you had more carbon tetrachloride,
you'd get shorter chains if you had less,
you get longer chain,
so you can control it. But not
precisely. There's, uh, there's, uh,
a property called dispersity, which is,
they're not all exactly the same length.
They're average that, but some are longer,
some are shorter. And how wide is this,
uh, determined something about obviously
the properties of the material you get.
Okay. We won't go into that any further.
Now. Alkene and dying oligomenorrhea,
ization and polymerization using carbon
electrified as the active reagents.
Now all ago means a few.
So Alla [inaudible] is putting
just a few such units together.
And so we're, we're going to
use either a sigma star of our,
with the leaving group or, uh, or, uh,
our cad ions as the reagent
to do the polymerization.
So if you have a r plus as an electrified,
will you do a really interesting reaction?
Notice you can take ISO butane and
isobutylene react them with h two,
so four,
and add the elements of the ISO butane.
And I've colored them because you can
do isotopic labeling to see what's what.
Notice that what added to the
owl Keane was this ch sigma bond.
What do you like?
How do you like that Noel?
He see any problem with
doing a reaction like that?
What's the homo at Lumo of the,
of the purple molecule here.
There's no functional group
there. How can you do it? Well,
tell me what would happen first.
If you have concentrated sulfuric acid
and react with this mixture. Where do you,
what do you think would happen
first?
Where is there a functional group?
The five on?
So, so the Proton would attack
the Pi electrons. And what,
at which end would it attack?
Would you put the Proton here or would
you put the dot on the more substituted
carbon?
It'd be more cognitive of, you'd want
to get a t beautiful cat. Yeah. Okay.
So we'll, so we'll do that. Incidentally,
this product was not irrelevant because
that's what they mean when they say
octane.
That compound is defined as 100
octane for the engine performance.
So this was,
uh,
we had worked on during the Second World
War to try to make high quality fuel
for airplanes. Okay. So we put the,
we'll follow what Noel says and put
then make the tea butyl cad ion.
And now the t beautiful cat. Diane can
react with the Al keen to give this.
And now you'd say,
why don't we just keep going?
Well it depends on what the,
on what the situation is and
you'll see it can do that. But,
but another thing it can do is
react with this. Watch this, right?
This is a tertiary cad ion,
but it's rather hindered,
right? This one, if you transfer
this with its electrons,
curved Arrow there, right?
That's a hydride shift.
We've seen hydride shifts
before the differences.
This is happening between two molecules
rather than for one car over to the next
to the same molecule.
But it was shown by Bartlett in
1944 that this process that happens,
use it isotopic labels,
right?
So it gives ISO octane and what's the
other product? What's the purple product?
The h one, the hydride, not Proton.
Hydride the h with its electrons.
What up here? What was left
behind the TV at OCAD iron.
But that's what you need here. So this
is a chain. It could go round and round.
So you add ISO butane to
isobutylene right now,
uh, if you, if you don't
have the ISO butane in there,
then it turns out that it could
do this polymerization. Right?
I had another one and another
one, et Cetera, et cetera.
And that gives poly isobutylene,
which is called butyl rubber.
And it's not a very strong material,
but it has the virtue of being air tight.
So that's what's made to seal a tires
when they made inner tubes and those days
they were made out of butyl rubber,
right to hold the air in.
Okay.
So now these electro files in
terpene and steroid biogenesis.
Uh,
now I've got to get onto this next time,
but I want,
but since I brought stuff here,
I'm going to entertain you
with a show and tell. It does,
it comes after this set of slides,
but uh, but since I got it here,
I'm going to do it.
So we'll turn on the light here.
And what I have
here is water and vinegar,
diluted Siddique acid and this stuff that
I bought down at the art supply store
called mold builder.
But if I read here,
it says it's ammonia,
a 100% natural latex.
That means that came right
out of the tree and water.
So all that's in here is tree,
SAP and water and ammonia,
right? So I want to pour
some into the water here.
I'm going to take my jacket off
and took my tie and actually
make that white fruit,
okay?
So we're going to open it up here
and I'll pour some in there.
Okay? Now the ammonia keeps, the
molecules will talk about this next time,
uh,
apart from one another of this light tax.
All
right?
But if we add some vinegar,
it'll get rid of the ammonia.
Obviously I didn't measure it very
carefully. Oh, there we, we're doing it.
So now the molecules are coming together,
okay?
So if I reach in here and grab it,
get rid of that water
drive a few times here.
So we've made a rubber ball.
Good. Okay. That anybody wants to make
a rubber ball, you can done and do it.
Thank you.